gotta say something man we got some
idiots some food some jackasses on
television that really just pissed me
off
talking about
Josh should make a stand saying he
didn't break any laws he didn't do
anything wrong we in a state where you
can carry your gun those guys are just
he's just freaking idiots and I
understand for you because y'all won't
let me say what I want to say
we don't care for it it pisses me off
when I hear guys hit it yo man when
you're making a hundred million dollars
a year
to play sports
your life changes
there are certain rules and regulations
you have to live by plain and simple you
can't do stupid stuff that's the
trade-off now if you want to do all that
stuff and give all that money back more
power to you you can make that stand
says you know what I want to do what I
want to do
I want to flash my gun and make videos
and do things okay that's fine but you
can't make money on the NBA doing this
stuff
I I just hope that he grows up and
realize like yo man first of all you're
not a thug you're not a criminal you're
not a crook you're a guy making a
hundred million dollars a year to
dribble is 200 200 million to dribble a
stupid basketball and
we hit the lottery we all hit the
lottery to do something that's people
out there work nine to five eight and
nine hours a week gonna make 25 000 a
year they were killed to be in our
situation and
you know Kenneth's right at some point
it's not your friends be a part sales
used to always saying I love he says
your man you just an unlucky dude
bad stuff happen around you all the time
you're just an unlucky dude no no no man
you got to look in the mirror say yum
you know what maybe I'm the problem
and it's it's disappointing because the
kid's a great player but to be like to
be a fool already then be a bigger fool
a couple months later and this is like
your fifth or sixth gun thing
and like I say